this is the jocko unraveling podcast
number 35 with daryl cooper and myself
and we are
going to hit a subject that is
well i guess it's a it's a subject that
we kind of have to talk about
um
what is the subject is the subject mass
killings is that the subject that that
question is maybe the topic of the
episode yeah i mean is it a is it a the
subject mental health is it
firearms policy is it
the way we're raising our kids media
is it gone you know um i think that's
that's the question we really need to
discuss
here here's uh something to think about
as we go through this
let me give you a quote
if i cannot join them i will rise above
them and if i cannot rise above them i
will destroy them i've been trying to
join and be accepted among the beautiful
people popular people all my life but it
was to no avail
they have always treated me like scum
girls have always deemed me unworthy of
their love and sex i tried to overthrow
them by gaining wealth at a young age
from trying to come up with invention
ideas to contemplating writing an epic
story and finally trying to win the
lottery
at this point the prospect of
overthrowing them seemed helpless
the final solution to triumph over my
enemies was to destroy them to carry out
my day of retribution to exact my
ultimate and devastating vengeance
against all of the popular young people
who never accepted me and all against
all the women
for rejecting me and starving me of
their love and sex end quote and that's
elliot roger
who in 2014 committed a mass murderer up
in isla vista
california right out this university of
santa barbara i mean it's a
crazy place beautiful place
killed six
he died he committed suicide as well
injured 13.
he wrote this hundred thousand page or
sorry hundred thousand word
manifesto
which a book is you know like 70 80 000
words this guy this kid wrote a book and
you know there's there's there's weird
i mean
it's hard to figure out where to open up
this can
um because this was a kid who was
driving around in a new bmw that his mom
bought him so he'd feel better this is a
kid who had money
who had
you know he had connections his
parents were
well connected in hollywood his dad was
some kind of a is in the movie industry
and would go to
movie premieres and he would go to movie
premieres and things like this and
um
and this is a one-off case
and and and right now we're reeling from
the latest uh mass shooting down in
texas 18 year old male shot and killed
21 people 19 of which were
children
9 10
11 years old and you know what and two
of them were teachers but
you know nine 10 11 year old kids
aren't adults
they're not adults they don't have
it's hard even if you're angry at the
world and you're angry at humanity it's
kind of hard to put
a nine-year-old
in the category of humanity because they
don't they're not really a part of
humanity yet they're they're too young
they're not ha they're not doing any
evil things at nine years old at 10
years old
i mean it was even worse at sandy hook
where the kids were even younger than
that
um
and yet you know you sent over a quote
where where you know as you as you try
and categorize or you try and figure out
are you trying to put some
yeah you're try and categorize these
things
you look at the cal the columbine
shooters
this is from
uh a book
by sue klebold who is the the mother of
dylan klebold who was one of the
columbine shooters
she says dylan and eric
had already been in certain quarters
heralded as champions for a cause time
tom and i received chilling letters from
alienated kids expressing admiration for
dylan and what he'd done adults who had
been bullied as children wrote to tell
us they could relate to the boys and
their actions girls flooded us with love
letters
young men left messages on our answering
machine calling dylan a god a hero
an acquaintance working at a youth
correctional facility told me some of
the imprisoned boys cheered as they
watched the television coverage of the
destruction of the school
columbine-related materials were found
among virginia tech shooter
chose possession
and in the sandy hook elementary school
shooter adam lanza's belongings
so these guys
by some parts of society are being held
up as heroes and being imitated and i'm
sure we'll get to that
you see two other examples of that if
you go on to uh some of the
hardcore
like right wing you know white
supremacist angle like websites or even
things like 4chan 8chan things like that
you'll still still see people
on like 4chan and it's a minority and
people they'll usually get shouted down
by the rest of the people but in every
thread where it comes up you'll find
somebody or a couple people who heap
praise on anders breivik that killer
from norway from a few years ago uh
brendan taurant the one from new zealand
those people will pipe in
and uh you know i'm i'm assuming that
when anders breivik and brendan torrant
went onto those websites themselves they
probably saw
some people again not all but some
people praising i don't know the
columbine shooters or some other person
that they ended up imitating
now what's what's interesting about
the columbine shooters and you and you
and i were talking about this
before we pressed record
you sit back and i've got four kids you
don't have any kids yet
uh but i have four kids and
you think how does a parent
miss
kids that are plotting for
over a year
to do this
heinous act
but they really did a good job of sort
of masking their intentions yeah the
columbine one is
it's really hard to classify along with
the recipes like you can look at
something like kip kinkle which happened
a few months before columbine and oregon
you can look at adam lanza the sandy
hook killer
the buffalo shooter recently the kid
down in parkland florida a while back
and you look at those and you have this
this lone
this isolated loner
who who you know his personality is in
the process of disassembling essentially
and
you know maybe he's got
a single mother somebody around who who
should be watching them but they're not
and they're just sort of like left to
themselves to just degenerate into
something that could go do something
like that the columbine kids you know
pretty much every psychologist that's
ever looked at those two kids and we've
got a lot of material from them they
left us their journals they left us a
whole bunch of tapes they made together
they were in a very well
put together community and so they were
known to a lot of people you know they
had friends they had families etc they
had gone to the prom yeah right and
every psychologist that's really looked
at that has uh has come to the
conclusion these two kids were not out
of their minds or insane or whatever in
any way you know obviously you could
just say well if you're going to go
shoot up your school you're crazy but in
any way that we would normally classify
that in a medical sense that these kids
were not
mentally ill in that sense
and the
uh you know as far as like how you could
miss something like that again it's
columbine is really uh
it's an outlier in many ways because
these were two kids
who i mean columbine was a very high
agency
attack you know um they planned it for a
year like you said they had to do things
like as minors go out and procure
illegal firearms they had to hide them
from their parents and they went to
great lengths to do that in fact
one of eric harris's firearms wasn't
even found by the police in his room
when they went through and searched the
whole place and they were taking
everything tearing the whole place apart
it was found like months later
and um
you know they were taking they they
write about this and talk about this in
the videos how they were putting a lot
of work into
uh making sure their parents had no
inkling of what was going on making sure
their friends didn't know what was going
on the day of the attack you know they
had learned to make propane bombs and
pipe bombs their propane bombs thank god
didn't go off but they went through the
trouble of doing it they planted a bomb
across town to divert the police while
they were doing their attack
talking about a very high agency uh
almost like non-ideological terrorist
attack essentially um
where the two shooters don't
they're they're not eliot rogers these
these kids were you know they weren't
the varsity quarterback but they had a
big group of friends eric harris had
girlfriends both of them went to prom
like you said with dates the weekend
before
or two weekends before i think it was um
you know
and so
you know you look at somebody like adam
lanza you know there's a great
new yorker article that came out maybe
like
2015 or so about lanza and it is
incredibly haunting uh because it goes
through and just
describes you know he was with his
mother he hadn't seen his father in like
two years at the time of the shooting um
his father wasn't some evil guy or
anything he was just he lived a few
hours away it was a broken up marriage
and um the mother didn't really really
want him around
and it
adam lanza killed his mother obviously
but the father's still alive and so a
lot of the article is based on
discussions with the father and
you know
he
talks about
how you know his ex-wife the kid's
mother the kid he was an adult by this
point but lanza's mother
who he didn't have a good relationship
with the the husband um but he says like
she knew there was a problem and she was
trying and they go through all the
different ways that she was trying to to
get him help and
you know wasn't able to do that there
are a lot of other situations where you
look at them and
you just you know so many of these
situations where
these people are all but putting up a
billboard in times square saying i'm
gonna go kill a bunch of people
and nobody is paying attention
and it's hard to really understand how
that's even possible because you know in
this day and age i guess it's just the
parents
responsibility
maybe the fbi should somehow figure out
you know how to track these people and
identify them or whatever but
you know i think when you ask the
question of like hold on what do you
mean by that maybe the fbi should figure
out all these people these are like
solutions that people are kind of
putting out there who should be
responsible for like finding out who
these people are and tracking them
whereas if you you know because like the
real question right
is this is a question if you want to
talk about
the
gun policy angle or just the social and
cultural angle in general
you know a question i think really has
to be answered is it why did this stuff
not really happen before like the 1980s
there's a couple like things here and
there but really didn't happen much
there were plenty of guns there was
plenty of violence
um
and you know one of the things among
many that comes to mind is that you go
back a hundred years and if you had a
young male in
a community
who was starting to go a little bit off
the rails
in most cases it was not just
his mom who should have been watching
him you know there was an embeddedness
in like a whole social network a
community even if he was kind of an
outcast from the community people were
at least paying attention and knew who
he was he was known to people
and that these people would maybe be uh
corralled in a way
or at least noticed in a way that that
they're really not anymore
so just to put a little bit of um
a little a little bit of data behind
what we're talking about here this is a
a relatively new
phenomenon
and
you know when i when i was i was reading
through a bunch of these and
the first one i could find the first
kind of
lashing out at humanity
was the one that i found was in 1949
they called it the walk of death
a war veteran
1949 so the war's been over for four
years
he went out and sort of unprovoked shot
16 people
um
and so that happened in 1949
then there's like huge gaps where these
things don't happen and we don't get
into this sort of just
repetitive
killing
until what the last 20 25 maybe 30 years
since columbine yeah columbine seemed to
be a turning point of of sorts now look
there were some there were some other
there are some other pretty big ones um
um
i mean clearly we had the university of
texas right you had charles whitman he
formed a marine killed his wife and and
his mother and then killed this is 1966.
just before that 1965 there was a guy
the 16 year old kid
killed
killed uh stole his dad's gun on the and
killed three and then killed himself on
the on the
101 highway you know whitman left a note
telling people uh when you find my body
uh
do an autopsy and look at my brain
there's something wrong with my brain
and they did he had a giant tumor in his
brain
you get whitman that's 66. in the 60s
and 70s it's just out of control but
these are all sort of i mean for the
most part
political kind of these these
revolutionary killings um and by the way
you had that in the in the
early 1900s too right you had ma usually
these were either race or
um
racial events or or workers worker
events right unions
yeah anarchists were unions either
unions killing scabs or police killing
unions uh you had those things going on
but again these you could you could at
least
you you have some kind of reason behind
it sure before you get into these just
i'm gonna kill people that's the goal is
to kill people
um
you can kind of explain those the same
way you explain war and in our society
way of looking at things war is sort of
more
is a more legitimate means of that kind
of thing but to those people they see it
that way at least um
1976 cal state fullerton
a psychologically disturbed man killed
seven
1979 san diego cleveland elementary
school
that's right yeah yep uh brend brenda
spencer this is the girl that when they
asked her why she did it she said i
don't like mondays that's right um
82 there was a welding shop shooting
there was a uh tyrone mitchell
was that the san ysidro one no that was
killed two wounded twelve killed himself
uh he was one of your people from the
people's temple oh he was from jim jim
sure right yeah there were actually
several people's temples member members
who came out after that
and
did
some version of that murder suicide one
of them and that might have been him was
up on an overpass shooting at people
yeah and just so i don't get you in
trouble the reason i said that these are
that these are daryl's people is because
daryl did a fantastic
series podcast on his martyr made
podcast about the people's temple
uh so now we get to january or sorry
july 1984 this is san ysidro this is the
san ysidro mcdonald's massacre man san
diego popular for these matches and the
west coast in general um
for not only mass killers but also
serial killers which is something i
haven't been able to put two and two
together for but it's kind of
interesting
22 killed at the san ysidro mcdonald's
19 wounded
and this is a guy
who had asked for help like the day
before
um
didn't get a call back sat for hours
waiting for a call back after trying to
get you know an appointment at a mental
hospital or somebody to see him yeah
they spelled his name wrong it turns out
he he was a paranoid guy he was a
conspiracy guy he was um abused his wife
and daughters
and he called for help and didn't get it
um
86. this is where you get the first
post office shooting
15 killed six wounded and then suicide
it was a guy named patrick henry
cherelle
marine corps
this is the first of the postal incident
so you know you hear the term going
postal well here's why 1991 ridgewood
new jersey 1991 royal oak michigan 1993
dearborn michigan 1993 dana point
california 1995 montclair new jersey
1997 milwaukee wisconsin 2006 galetta
california this is where you get the
this is where you get the postal um
whatever urban
dictionary definition of going postal
and you know sometimes i wonder and i
maybe this is a topic conversation that
having to do sort of with the copycat
idea that um
you know just having the term going
postal
being in the air that everybody kind of
knows you almost wonder if
you know there are disgruntled employees
at workplaces all over the country
um but when that term's floating in the
air
some
percentage of like mentally disturbed
postal workers at a time are gonna i
could go you know it's like it's in the
air it's like an option this is this is
social contagion
that's what it is and well that's what
that is right there's something out
there it's in the air this is what's
happening this is what we're doing this
is what's going on
and this is a this is a
a thing that happens it's a social
contagion and social contagion
the the where this comes from i mean the
one of the examples that they use is
bulimia
so the fir
it first got published in the
journal of mental disorders it was in
like 1979
the guy says oh there's a disease it's
called bulimia where
you know people usually female
throw up their food after they eat it
and they get really sick and starve
after that got published
all of a sudden there was a lot more
cases now is part of that because now a
dad can say oh my daughter's doing this
i need to report her because i didn't
know what this was i thought she was
just you know
feeling sick and a bunch and maybe she
had something wrong with her stomach but
sure
some of it goes up but some of it was
people see it people see it's happening
they say the same thing about suicide
prevention hotline
posters
put those up in a community
suicide doesn't go down suicide goes up
there's there's a bunch of examples like
that cutting you know uh again this is
this is a phenomenon with with young
females usually where they cut
themselves
and it will spread through a community
suicide
adolescents who know about a friend's
suicide are nearly twice as likely to
attempt suicide within a year
this is a social contagion
it spreads there's clusters that's why
there's clusters of suicides one kid
kills themselves oh three four more they
all do the same thing it spreads
mass shootings
happens as well
i had a little quote from npr school
shootings and other shootings with four
or more deaths spread like a contagion
each shooting tends to spark more
shootings
there's something yeah back in the 1800s
something called the werther effect
based on gurtha's book the sorrows a
young worther he kills himself in a blue
shirt and a blue jacket and yellow pants
or maybe it's reversed in the book in
the 1800s there was a whole spate of
young dudes committing suicide wearing
that same outfit
so this stuff spreads
this stuff spreads there's there's we
can't even there's no doubt about this
this stuff it's psychotron it's like the
freaking hula hoop
um or the yo-yo you've seen that thing
recently where
young girls on tick tock are like
getting basically what looks like
tourette's
no yeah it's like this whole it was in
the new york times and stuff they were
writing about it apparently it's this
widespread epidemic of young girls who
are getting all of these ticks and weird
like tourette's uh symptoms
and it's spreading through tick tock
apparently which is just this is such a
whole new phenomenon that like is r if
you were to try to describe any of this
to people just a few years ago like they
wouldn't have i i don't know what to
make of it now
so this is one of the first thing that
gets thrown out you know when you talk
about these
what can we do about these things and
one of the first thing that gets thrown
out is well you know if we get rid of
guns or we
restrict guns more they'll be less of
these and then the immediate uh response
to that is often
hey
when i was growing up
people kids brought guns to school they
had a gun rack in their car that was
absolutely true with me i remember my
dad telling me that there was a guy in
his school my dad was a teacher my mom
was a teacher there was a they had a
shooting club and the teacher would sell
guns and do gun transactions in the
classroom
like oh yeah yeah bring the gun in you
know you want to sell it to billy cool
yeah you know daryl wants a new gun oh
billy's selling his bring it into school
there you go and by the way we're going
shooting after school
so
there's you know the guns have been
around for a long time look
are there things that could be done
there sure i'm sure there are
um
but to me
and and i was talking about this with my
daughter she's like well what is your
point she was my daughter was asked my
daughter's 22 years old she's you know i
was kind of talking about what we were
talking about today
and i had to think about that
she's you know she's like well you're
just gonna get there and
say everyone's killing each other and
that's the end you know that's what
that's what you're gonna offer people
well i don't know if i should or i don't
know if i can say this or i don't know
if i should say this or i don't know if
it even makes sense to say this
but it certainly seems to me
that this is a multi multi-faceted issue
where there's many many problems that
are all
that that by themselves
aren't that big of a problem
and they're very seldom a problem
but then when you take all these
facets and you join them together
occasionally on a very rare occasion
you get a you get you get a freaking
major catastrophic issue so
i mean what's a major catastrophic issue
is when a when a 18 year old goes out
and goes into a school and kills 19 kids
and two adults
that's that's like a major obviously a
major catastrophic issue
and then and then this is happening on a
regular basis so a fairly regular basis
i should say now you could look at all
these contributing factors to any of
these cases the availability of the guns
the availability of the access to the
places where they're going the lack of
law enforcement training
the use of
psychological drugs
the use of social media the the the
playing of first-person shooter video
games
the like we could go on with this this
the the glamorizing of
violence in hollywood and here so so you
can take all those things
look violent video games
does
99.9 of the population enjoy and play
those and has no negative effects
uh psychological drugs that are
prescribed by doctors does 99.9 of the
population
use those to good effect and helps them
cope with whatever they're dealing with
yes absolutely violent movies don't 99.9
of people go to a violent movie and say
wow i i got to experience this
horrible war i'm glad i don't have to
really live through that yes
don't most don't 99.9 of people use
firearms for protection or
you know for either household protection
or they they like to shoot because they
like the the skill of shooting or
they go hunting yes so you got all these
things that by themselves
99.9 of the time
it's not that it's it's fine it's
perfectly fine so to sit and condemn
video games or to condemn violent movies
or to condemn
uh you know weapons or to condemn
drugs psycho what do we call psychiatric
drugs i guess psychiatric drugs
psychotropic drugs to condemn these
things and say well we just have
something
you can't really do it because there's
too many people that benefit from these
things
and look there's people that benefit
from having a nice
escape from their reality they're
sitting in a cubicle all day they get
home at night they want to play freaking
call of duty and it's fun
and they get to experience something and
it gets their adrenaline going and they
make friends okay
someone goes and see a violent movie
okay someone listens to
music with violent lyrics okay
someone goes to a counselor and gets
prescribed drugs like okay there's all
these things that
when you take them individually
you know if you were to do an
operational risk assessment which we did
in the military
alone each one of these things has such
a low probability
of causing a problem that you you would
you would okay the mission you say yeah
okay there's a 99.9 chance that this is
fine cool and here's the benefits okay
but when you put all these things
together
then you have occasionally
that 0.01
chance that it messes this guy up in
such a way and then there's also a 0.01
chance that he also happens to be on
this drug and a point zero one chance
that he also happens to
to to see a violent movie where this
stuff is depicted and then you end up
with a catastrophic scenario
so
what i was getting at earlier is
it seems like we need to
make a cultural
adjustment in a whole bunch of areas and
that's such a huge thing to say that
it's kind of like saying well you know
we're we're in war what should we do we
should win the war so it's almost it's
almost a worthless statement that i'm
making
that being said are there things that we
can do
i think there are
um i
i think that it's worth talking about
the mental health aspect a little bit
more deeply i was doing some research on
the trend of uh deinstitutionalization
that took place really it was it started
in the 50s and really accelerated in the
70s and 80s and kind of consummated in
the 80s and just to i'm sure you're
going to say this but
de-institutionalization that means
before in the past
if you were
mentally unstable if you had issues
they were going to take you and they're
going to put you somewhere what
sunnydale you know mental hospital or
whatever the arkham asylum whatever the
whatever the stereotypical name is of a
place where they take people that are
having
mental issues and they take them and put
them there yeah and the mentality was
uh you know that if you are presenting
in a way that
people around you feel is threatening um
we're going to put you away
whether you like it or not and you will
get out when we feel confident that it's
safe to let you out
now of course you know as you got into
the 60s and 70s
it was really this confluence of two
forces right where you had the liberal
activists who were looking at a
situation like that and for sure there
were people who
were being committed who probably
shouldn't have been there were husbands
who didn't want their wives around who
were having them committed
there were several like very high
profile scandals where
the patients were just being radically
neglected and mistreated and you know
very publicized and so there was a big
backlash against it at the same time
where you had uh you know where from the
conservative side who might you know be
more interested in sort of social
control and that kind of thing wanted to
cut budgets
and so these two things kind of came
together and you went from a situation
in 1955 where
you had 340 mental health patient beds
per 100 000 americans
to 2008 i think it is 2007 uh where
there are 17 beds per 100 that's a 95
decrease
in the you know the inpatient resources
that are available over this period of
time and so we ask what does that mean
and you say
uh what that is but by the way we're
doing that so we're getting rid of
you know 95 of the opportunities for
people that have mental health issues to
go
and get help and be somewhere where
they're not going to hurt themselves
they're not going to hurt anybody else
and then on top of that you throw into
the societal mix
the mayhem the the violence the first
person shooter games the drugs that
people are on whether they're prescribed
or or they're illegal
and then you put them in a social media
world where they're they're by
themselves where they're outcast where
they're they're alone and a social media
world that lacks any of like the
accountability or the guard rails of
like normal
in-person physical interaction you know
um and so what you're you know what
you're left with when you see that is
like that there are
uh
rad i mean many times you know with 95
percent decrease if you just take that
number that you say there are 20 times
the number of people walking around
among us today
who in 1955 would not have been allowed
to do that
now some of those people shouldn't have
been in those places but maybe
the bottom line is there's a massive
number of people walking among us today
who in the past would not have been
allowed to do that
and
you know it's
it's always tough right because i mean
you know like for example even when
people talk about mental health checks
for firearms like i understand
for sure
why everybody is uncomfortable with that
because there are a lot of people out
there who think that
um i don't know if you think that um you
know climate change is such a big issue
that like these oil companies have to be
stopped no matter what or if you think
the 2020 election was stolen or whatever
it is that maybe you know your
conspiracy theory adult brain over there
like is not fit to have a firearm and
there are people worried about that i
understand those fears like for good
reason
but the bottom line i think uh or maybe
it's not the bottom line but it's worth
noting that there are people out there
who are legally allowed to buy a gun
today who a few decades ago would not
have legally been allowed on the street
period
and
you know there are going to be
consequences for something like that i
mean you talk about um
what's his name james huberty the guy
from san ysidro
mcdonald's shooting back in 84.
tells his wife the day before i've got
mental health issues i'm going to do
something terrible
spends hours on the phone trying to get
an appointment with a mental hospital or
get in to see somebody to get some kind
of help
waits around you know doesn't get any
call back 48 hours later says he's gonna
go hunt some humans and heads into a
mcdonald's and
kills like 25 people or something like
that you know
and that's the kind of thing that would
not have happened back when there were
inpatient beds per 100 000 people right
because there's a bunch of logistics
behind that administrative
uh support and
yeah it's it's it's a very very bizarre
situation where you hear about mental
health all the time this is sort of a
trending topic on a daily basis and and
maybe i see a lot of it from the veteran
community and the veterans talk about
mental health but i also see it from the
first responder community but then you
also see it at large people talk about
mental health mental health mental
health and here we are where in 1955
there was 340 mental health inpatient
beds for every hundred thousand and now
there's only 17. so as much as we're
talking about mental health
we've gone in the opposite direction of
being able to support these people now
listen
you go and watch one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
and you think hey this is this is
horrible and we shouldn't put anybody in
an institution in a mental institution
so i'm sure that that movie one of that
movie come out 70s maybe early 70s yeah
so so
that's the kind of thing where you see
you have an extreme backlash
against
like you said people get abused and oh
it's sort of like um you know even even
one of the principles in america is we'd
rather have you know
a hundred guilty people go free than one
innocent person be convicted and
sent to prison or or put to death the
question here is would you like to have
100 guilty people go free uh as opposed
or rather would you would in order to
get that one innocent person from
getting stuck in a place like that are
you willing to uh allow 100 people to go
shoot over school
that's what i'm saying so it's you can
use sort of the same argument or i'm
sure that argument was used
when you look at hey the and you know
this person was put this this woman was
putting a psychiatric word by her
husband who was an evil guy who
gaslitter and you know called and
planted stuff on her and now she's stuck
in this place and go people that should
never happen
and and now we've gone so far in the
other direction where we only have 17
beds for every hundred thousand and
listen you don't have to be a freaking
rocket scientist to realize that out of
a population of a hundred thousand
you've got more than 17 people that need
some some mental health
help
there's no doubt about that
and it's also interesting
you know what what's going on with the
homeless population you know what
percentage of homeless population
is has mental health disorders and i was
talking to a police officer the other
day
and he was just explained to me said you
know like
we we
want to help these people
we want to help these people they don't
belong in prison
but guess what you put them on the
street what are they going to do they
got to eat they they're crazy so they're
yelling at people someone someone says
something back to him and they attack
him they don't belong in prison they're
they're they're mentally not well and so
the fact that we've
shut down these types of institutions to
send people that need help is wrong
so this is a huge part of this and in
talking that police officer
you know it's one of those problems that
the police have
and that's why like we live in san diego
san diego has a a pretty bad homeless
problem depending on where you go
and if you go and you observe those
homeless people or you talk to those
homeless people they're not they're not
mentally there a lot of them
a lot of them are not mentally there
they you can tell you can look at them
for five seconds you can say hi to him
and you can tell that they have some
kind of mental issue going on
i would say 90 of them well no i would
say maybe 70 of them probably the other
a bunch of them
have you know alcohol and drug problems
yeah a lot of the ones that don't
you don't really see
you know they stay out of the way you
don't see them wandering the streets and
stuff so yeah
so this is a a huge thing that we need
to look at and again i guess i guess
what we should just break this down and
sort of like what things can we look at
to try and improve
and and decrease
these situations well i think we we have
to one thing we have to admit though is
that it's
you know it's not homeless some crazy
homeless person who's getting his hands
on a gun and going and shooting a bunch
of places up
and you know the thing that this is
another thing that can come up in the in
the discussion about like firearms
policy but it's
i think a critical question because it
i wrote it in the notes here which is
that you look at like the inner cities
you know the the black inner cities
where there's plenty of guns
there's lots of gun violence you know
south side chicago whatever what you
don't have
is some 14 year old who decides to just
wander into his school and just kill as
many random people as possible it just
didn't really happen maybe it's happened
once or something i couldn't find it
actually if it had you have like mass
shootings that will count in fbi
statistics but you know those are like i
hate that guy i'm gonna shoot over there
and i hit five people or something gang
related yeah and i don't think anybody
means that when they talk about these
things and so like you have to ask that
question like why
you know
like like i think for example
you know if you have uh
you talk about like cutting suicide all
of these things all of these issues
bulimia all these things have all
radically increased over the last 20 25
years since the late 90s right you have
a massive increase in suicide rates
especially among young people and uh
other types of self-harm cutting things
like that patient admissions for that
you have
a huge explosion of these you know riots
that when we get into it and we look at
like you know some people there are
activists some people are like hardcore
political radicals but there's a ton of
like mentally unstable
like like in the in the kenosha thing
with kyle rittenhouse one of the guys he
shot had like gotten out he was like
this just a completely insane pedophile
who was
we have a huge explosion of that kind of
behavior you have uh you know we start
seeing maybe back in the late 2010s
start getting all these videos of these
uh you know people on these kids on
college campuses who apparently are
completely emotionally unable to handle
like just very basic
obstacles in their life having emotional
breakdowns and over you know very small
things you have
like widespread youth identity crises
you know whether it's an explosion of
the trans phenomenon but then also like
you know that's kind of been expanded
out now you have
all these
spin-offs right like people who think
they're unicorns people who think that
they're mythical creatures or you know
the furries or just all of these other
strange things that you know are sort of
spreading like a social contagion
and you look at all of that
and i look at all of it and i ask well
hey like
maybe all of that is connected somehow
and maybe
you know when a girl is having certain
kinds of problems she goes and hurts
herself
and maybe when a boy does that he goes
and hurts other people you know
sometimes and it may be this is all kind
of part of the same
uh
same phenomenon that's going on i mean
when you look at the mental health
numbers like i wrote some of them down
here among young people
the rate of this one's for adults but uh
the rate of suicidal ideation among
adults has increased every year since
2011 to 2012. so first of all just right
there that's 10 years straight of
increase
anxiety disorders among 18 to 25 year
olds doubled between 2008
2018. um and and when you think about
that 28 2008 2018 you're not talking
about the same group people are more
anxious talking about different groups
of people right so in 2008
an 18 year old was born in 1990 in 2018
that 18 year old was born in you know uh
2000 probably had an iphone at 10 years
old a lot of these other type of social
changes were talking about
among high school students between 2009
and 2019 is according to the cdc a 40
increase in persistent feelings of
sadness sadness and or hopelessness 36
increase in
answering that i've seriously considered
attempting suicide and in another uh
episode
back that we did i mentioned cdc's
mental health survey last year in 2021
where they came out and said for people
between 16 and 24 years old male and
female combined
the people the number of people
who answered yes to the question have
you seriously considered and seriously
was in the answer have you seriously
considered committing suicide in the
last 30 days
male and female between 16 to 24 26 said
yes 26
now
you know
you you hear that like my response to
that when i saw that when i was hearing
about it was like how how are we not
like
stopping everything calling an emergency
congressional session to like figure out
why a quarter of our young people said
that they thought about killing
themselves in the last seriously thought
about killing themselves in the last 30
days
um
and
you know but not only is that not
happening like it didn't even make the
papers
you know forget about the front page
like you couldn't find it on page six
and so this is just kind of happening in
the background and we're not
addressing it really at all
and you you know um in 2021 just last
year and obviously you have to take
covet into account for this one 44 of
high school students
reported feeling persistently sad or
hopeless for a period of at least one
month at some point in the past year
you know and so you think like all right
so we radically decreased
our public resources that are devoted to
mental health care
we put tens of millions of kids on
psychotropic drugs for which we have no
long-term data on how this affects you
if you take it for 20 30 40 years or
whatever
uh
just radically ramped up the level of
like ultra violence and extreme
sexuality in
media that kids are exposed to uh video
games etc and again it's one of those
things where
it's it's not a single cause and i
understand why people because most
people are fine and they get offended
when you you know sort of like the same
reason a lot of
there's a lot of veterans groups and
stuff who get a little uncomfortable
with
the way some people handle the ptsd
conversation because they don't want to
stigmatize the large majority of people
who don't who don't have those issues or
even the ones who do
it's the same thing with like media and
video games a lot of people that watch
them who are just fine but the bottom
line is
you know kids grow up watching today
a lot of kids i mean a whole lot of kids
it is common to grow up watching
or playing things that would have gotten
you thrown in prison 50 or 60 years ago
for trying to release no [__] like that
is that is the reality and then we you
know profoundly
disordered our
uh sexual norms
our sort of courtship you know norms
between like young people or even adult
people and radically disrupted the
family structure and we did all of those
things i just listed over the course of
about 20 years
and then
during that same period of time we see a
huge ramp up in serial killers in the
70s and 80s
then a whole bunch of mass shootings
starting in the 80s and really ramping
up in the late 90s up until now
and
you know our answer to that is well it
must be the guns that were always there
to begin with and that exist in the
ghetto
that where they don't have any of these
issues
and there's just a whole bunch of other
reasons like and i'm not saying like
look if you could snap your fingers
and every firearm on the planet would
just disappear uh yeah we'd probably
have a lot fewer of these things you'd
have fewer wars too um obviously that's
not an option you know i'm not saying
that's like not something that would be
a prophylactic if you could actually
pull it off
but you know i i feel like the firearms
discussion a lot of ways
it's a way for us and i'm not saying
people are doing this tactically i think
it's almost like a psychological defense
almost in a way where
it's it's something that we can latch on
to as a as a tangible solution that
seems you know like it could just
physically stop the thing from happening
so that we don't have to look at any of
these other things in any serious way
because doing so would mean
you know considering the possibility
that just a huge number of all of these
social trends and cultural trends that
we've all been embracing for the last 50
or 60 years we're all a huge mistake
and that we've done profound damage to
our children to our culture
and that in that undoing some of that
damage would mean
well i mean you know undoing whole
industries that's one aspect is an
economic and financial aspect of it but
also just admitting that like because
it's not as if we just did these things
for money we did it because we thought
it was the right thing to do it seemed
like we were liberating people we were
you know all of these things that came
out of the 60s and 70s and having to
reevaluate all that
um
you know as you were talking about that
and and we were talking earlier
you and i before we pressed record we're
talking about the fact that
if you were to look at what you and i
were like and the people that we knew
you and i could name
10 15 people each that when we were
growing up or people that we
you know knew or associated with or at
least knew in our school or you know
from wherever from you know the scene
you go man this dude's a little bit
crazy i look at some of the stuff that i
wrote when i was freaking 15 16 years
old
it's it's it's not healthy you know it
certainly doesn't seem healthy uh you
know talking about getting after it
talking about killing talking about
death talking about all those things i
would i would write about those things
when i was a kid
15 16 years old
14 years old
even younger than that i got freaking
taken to the counselor at my school
cause i wrote a poem about death when i
was like uh
i want to say i was in sixth grade
sixth grade i wrote a poem about death
it was pretty cool i had i i in the poem
i took a i drew like a grim reaper and
his sickle and underneath his sickle was
this poem about death and they were like
oh my gosh you see stuff like that too
yeah so there you go so
stuff like that happens right and you
when you're growing up you're dealing
with these things
and and my point in saying that is like
okay so
kids think about some crazy [__] when
they're younger
and then what happens to them what do
you say to them and and you get this
thing now where
um
some of it's kind of encouraged whether
it's encouraged by your your peers you
know the social media
the the people that are looking around
you going oh yeah that's great it's
almost like positive that you feel bad
that you're telling everyone
and and this is where you get this
horrible dichotomy because
some people that have it if you have
some mental issues you've got some stuff
you've got to work through it it's
really good in most cases you go and
talk to somebody about it and get those
things off your chest and tell people
how you feel and the people say okay i
understand here's what you can do to
help
and no one really says like yeah hey
dude everyone kind of feels that way
you're young you'll get over it push
through it
which
is something that also can help you when
you're young and you got
dumped by the girl
or you got rejected by the girl or your
friends you know aren't hanging out with
you or you're frustrated because you're
not as smart as you wanted to be or you
didn't make the football team all these
things that piss you off when you're
young and someone goes hey dude yeah
suck it up
try harder work harder
doesn't it
one more thing because because you you
led me right into this
discipline equals freedom right
discipline equals freedom is
a it's a saying that i've said it's a
book that i've written
and
it's true if you want to have freedom in
life you you you need to start with
discipline
and so what you would the entire tan the
entire tirade that you just went on
about all these things that we've done
which we did in a positive way or at
least with a positive mindset of hey
we're gonna liberate we're gonna open up
people's minds we're going to let people
be free
and do whatever you want to do kind of
and say whatever you want to say kind of
and and yet with that just
unmitigated freedom
all of a sudden there's no boundaries
and all of a sudden there's no
difference between right and wrong and
all of a sudden you can literally do
whatever you want and that is when you
run into a problem
so when you've taken away a lot of these
societal norms
and the the discipline that comes from
society that you get told hey man you
can't do that
hey quit acting like that
hey what do you what no we don't do that
stop doing that
who's saying that right now who's who
who's whose discipline who's putting
discipline who's putting structure
around a 16 year old kid
that is going in a bad direction
and his parents
don't say hey hey you can't do that you
can't act like that
hey if you do that again i'm gonna
you're gonna get in trouble here's the
here's the punishment
here's what's gonna happen
and and if you know anything about me i
i am not a tyrannical parent at all in
fact i i always constantly tell people
like when my when my kids were younger
they didn't even have a curfew
none of them come home come home when
you're done
i was not a not a tyrannical parent at
all i gave them a lot of freedom
but my kids also knew like hey here's
the box if you step out of this box it's
going to be an issue
it's going to be a big issue
so you can you can have a lot of freedom
but here are the norms that you have to
sort of remain within and if you want to
push outside those norms okay come and
talk to me about it maybe you've got a
point that i don't understand that's
okay
but there's probably also some things
that you don't understand maybe you
don't understand how this is going to
impact the rest of your life maybe this
is you don't understand how this might
impact your your relationship with other
people maybe you don't understand how
this could impact your future and so
you put that you put your kids into a
box and make that box as big as you can
but
i think right now there's a lot of kids
where they're the boxes just wide open
do whatever you want and not only is
your behavior that's outside the box not
only is it accepted
it's encouraged
it's completely encouraged
and so that's what we have to be careful
of i would say i'm so lucky that i
joined the military because i had a
bunch of excess energy that i could have
put in a million different bad places
and thankfully i joined the military and
was like oh here's the box
here's where you can put this energy
you can expend as much of that energy as
you want as long as it's in this
direction over here and you'll be
rewarded for it
and you'll be doing something
positive and i didn't i wasn't
smart enough to even understand that
but i understood okay there's the box i
can stay inside this box here's where i
can focus my energy
i was listening a while back to a
podcast conversation uh between eric
weinstein and the author brett easton
ellis and they were talking about
growing up in los angeles in like the
70s and 80s
and how
sometime like around maybe the mid to
late 70s or so
i can't remember which of them they put
it this way is he he was maybe eric who
said he just sort of like woke up one
day and sort of like noticed for the
first time that like
well like all of a sudden like all of my
friends parents are divorced
like
you know maybe that wasn't true in like
montana as much but in a place like you
know los angeles and the communities
they were in hollywood or whatever uh it
was much more true and so very very
clustered in certain ways in urban areas
but this is something that like when you
look at it you know radically ramped up
in the 70s and 80s i mean tripled the
divorce rates in the country and
it's very very well known if if just
about anything is well established in
social science when it comes to this
stuff right now it's that fatherlessness
or weak father figures but
fatherlessness in general because the
others harder to quantify
um
definitely connected with higher rates
of violence including these mass
shootings and
you know
i i i i think it's like part of a larger
trend
that
remember when we did our episode on the
media
i mentioned how you go back to like 1940
and there's very few televisions in the
united states most places don't happen
you get up to 1950
or rather 1960 you got 50 million
households with televisions and when you
look at like 16 1965 1970 the average
kid is watching television something
like four to six hours a day
and
like on average like those are the
national averages and i think that with
that family breakdown
with the sort of changes and adult
behavioral norms that happened in the
late 60s and in the 70s and kind of
continued on
with the entry of mothers into the
workforce
just all of these different changes and
family structure and and social norms
that a huge amount of
of of parenting kind of got outsourced
to the media right which meant basically
like you know you're letting i mean you
see us today like you see like some
two-year-old who's just sat there on
youtube you know his mom doesn't want to
have him go crazy or whatever at the
restaurant so she just gives him the
phone lets him watch youtube for as long
as it takes and it's like i totally
understand that obviously like that's
you know being a parent of a young child
is incredibly energy sapping and
difficult and you know if you can get
them to just let you have a few minutes
i totally understand that but what has
happened over like several decades and
started back in the 60s
is the outsourcing of a lot of parenting
to the media now you know when i was a
kid i watched a lot of tv
but i think back to like what that tv
was because i grew up without a father
my whole life my parents divorced when i
was two and he never got replaced so had
a single mom growing up the entire time
now
i was fortunate enough that you know i
had an uncle and a grandfather who were
like strong figures that i could sort of
model
um and i had a few coaches things like
that that came along critical times and
that was good
but also like you know some portion of
my
of my capacity to model like what does a
man
behave like what does a family look like
a normal family because i didn't really
have a normal kind of you know family
like you're sort of bourgeois american
family i wasn't my family and so what
does that look like how how would i be
an adult like how can i when i get to
that point
well i think back to the tv that i was
watching and we were watching like i
remember every friday night they had
this like it was a series of shows they
called tgif and it was like full house
family matters
uh
step by step and you know all of them
were kind of strange families for the
sake of comedy you know it was a these
were sitcoms but they were all basically
functional
uh caring
middle class families that you could
look at and sort of as a model for how a
household would function right
um kids today don't watch that stuff if
they watch tv at all
um you know they're they're playing
video games more um if they you know
they're they're on tick tock or whatever
so they're lacking even that
you know the thing that that at least i
had resource to when i was a kid and so
i think like i remember you know the
other day
we had to get our uh our deck replaced
our front deck replaced at our house
and um the guys who came to do it was a
father and a son the son was maybe like
in his early 20s or something and i was
like oh damn like this is the first time
i've had to have some work done at my
house in the last 10 years
that i've had somebody show up who is
less than like 40 years old you know if
not older because
uh it just seems strange right you just
don't see a lot of young guys who who
are doing stuff like that who are
capable of it and i think when you know
when i hear something like that elliot
rogers
uh screed that you read but a lot of
these guys the columbine kids included
um is i see a bunch of young dudes
who have no idea
how to behave as an adult man in the
society and they get to this point where
that period of that point in their life
is fast approaching
where they are going to have to go out
and be a man now and they have no idea
what that looks like and the whole idea
of it is like
it's just completely daunting it's
completely overwhelming and they're just
like i'm not i'm not doing that and i'm
not going to go out and prove myself a
failure to everybody that knows me all
the people that always look down on me
or whatever i'm not going to go confirm
all of that by going out and being a
failure in my life
and you know i i think like uh
i just yeah i feel like that's a big
part of it is people like we're you know
our teenagers are not growing up and
like learning how to be adults
you know my wife and i were talking
about this the other day like how
um you know we kind of uh during cove
had gotten that habit a lot of times we
we started using some of those grocery
delivery services we were like damn this
is actually like really convenient so
like we do it quite a bit now
but you know we were talking about we're
like you know we have kids like we have
to actually go do this because we need
to bring them along and they'll hate it
because kids hate doing stuff like that
but they need to go and be like oh this
is how you go to the store this is how
you interact with people all of these
adult things they need to they need to
watch and learn and figure out how to
model themselves you know in order to
function in society when they get older
and i feel like there's a huge deficit
of that and
again even the portion of it that used
to be taken up by media even that's
vacated anymore for the most part well
they have a word for it now adulting
right you've heard that expression it's
like what am i actually doing stuff
that's adult like
and and now i'm adulting and and
that's another interesting thing
i think i think jordan peterson asks
somebody asked me at some point what's
what's the problem
what's the what's what's what's causing
a lot of these problems in america and i
said something long lines oh well one of
the problems is that there's there's not
enough problems and
again this sounds like uh
well there's a bunch of people that have
all kinds of problems right i mean you
could have illnesses you got money
problems so there's problems in the
world but
to your point
look
it's really easy you know to call uh or
to to press a button on the phone and
get amazon to show up it's really easy
to find a dopamine hit from looking at
tick tock or instagram it's really easy
to get a dopamine hit from getting some
likes from some friends on your
on your phone
and you used to have to earn those
dopamine hits a little bit more you know
you had to go outside you had to do
something you had to make something you
had to build something you had to do
something and now it's just kind of free
dopamine out there and and then what
happens is you fast forward from age 10
to 20
and all you've done is gotten fast quick
dopamine hits from your phone
instead of getting a dopamine hit from
changing your oil and getting a dopamine
hit from building a shed outside and
getting a dopamine hit from playing a
cool song on your guitar and getting a
dopamine hit from going up and talking
to a girl for the first time like all
these things that you would get dopamine
from
all of a sudden you're just getting it
from your phone and you've acquired no
skills you can't talk to anybody you can
because let's face it when you're a when
you're a 10 11 12 year old
kid boy
going and talking to a girl is like a
big deal and you're going to get that
dopamine hit you're going to feel good
about it hey man if you can just turn to
your phone and get a dopamine hit and
basically see girls
as much girls as you want to see and see
girls in a way that you can
you know you can fantasize about but you
can get it right from your phone all of
a sudden you've lost the ability to
communicate with people you don't know
how to change your oil you don't know
how to build anything you don't know how
to take care of yourself you don't know
how to take care of anybody else and
yeah you look up when you're 20 years
old and
you're in a bad situation and no idea
how to
do anything that can't be it takes more
than one step to accomplish right yeah
you actually have to encounter
resistance and just understand that it
just takes work now and you have to kind
of go
zero when you've been in and you know
you can blame that on the person
themselves if you if they want but like
if that's how you've been raised since
you were eight years old
and you know i think maybe we're over
indexing on this a little bit um
at least in my mind because you know i'm
i'm still going back to
this fact that you brought up of 1955
340 uh beds in patient beds
down to 17 in patient beds
if you take that and i again i recognize
that you know you said well it's not
homeless people that are running around
shooting people up yeah i get it's not
homeless people but the homeless people
are uh uh
a symptom of that problem right so you
have you have this many homeless people
well you've got also then a kid
that
is
depressed is angry
he's got issues and he's not getting the
help that's a supermarket shooter in
buffalo he got he
people you know he was telling people
i'm gonna go kill a bunch of people so
they grabbed him they put him in a
hospital they held him for 48 hours let
him go zero follow-up
and it's like
you know what we used to do in a
situation like that and
i and i understand all of the potential
issues with something like this but i
don't know if i
really can see another
solution that doesn't require decades of
social reform and cultural change that
you know
is if you're a young dude
and you say in front of much people i'm
gonna go shoot at my school or anything
like that you get arrested immediately
and put put away in a mental pla you
know place where you can be looked after
i'm not talking about jail
but a mental care facility and you get
out when we feel like it's safe to let
you out and no sooner and
you know that's gonna that's gonna mean
that like some dude who's just being an
edge lord you know and like talking [__]
trying to get a rise out of people or
whatever uh is gonna get put away and
maybe he was just joking or whatever um
that dude you know uh
is going to
i think that'll come out over time and
it will suck that that happens to him
but everybody else is going to be like
do you hear what happened to johnny he
was talking that [__] about wanting to
go to school he was just joking they put
him away that maybe the social norms
would kind of change where you know yeah
well you start to get that societal
pressure on people to go oh yeah you
can't act like that bro you can't do
that we're not doing that
and and here's the thing this is what
this
this um
this fact you know you hear about mental
health and and you often hear it it's it
is going back to the homeless thing what
the hell can you do about it what could
you possibly do about it it's like oh
we used to do something about it we used
to have 347
inpatient beds
how many you know how many outpatient
beds did they have at that or how many
outpatient
doctors that were ready to do help help
someone so
there's there's
you know something that we need to go
back to
go back to the fact that we used to take
people that were having mental health
issues and we would take them and put
them somewhere where they could get them
some help where they wouldn't hurt
themselves and where they wouldn't hurt
anybody else
and this is something that we used to do
95 more than we do it now
i mean can you imagine there's a hundred
thousand bed 340 beds for a hundred
thousand people there's what three
million people in san diego
right that's a lot that's that's taking
a thousand peep that's opening up a
thousand beds
if you took a thousand p people and put
them in mental health care in san diego
california you would have all kinds of
improvements around here
you'd have all kinds of improvement and
you'd help those people get their lives
back together get their get them the
psychiatric help that they need get the
medication that they need or the
counseling that they need put them in an
environment where they can actually do
something productive
and
we just we we've lost our way on that
yeah and people will say they'll point
back to the old days
and say you know that there were these
high-profile disasters where people were
not being taken care of were being
abused
um they'll point and just say look
a lot of these people were not being
helped by these places it was just a
place to keep them and that's true do
better but that's the thing we're
talking about a period of time we're
like we didn't really know what ptsd was
like you come back from combat you're
completely screwed up from everything
you've experienced and they're just like
always shell-shocked or something so i
mean this was a different era where
we've got a you know we've got 50 years
more of psychological research and
understanding clinical data to draw on
not to mention the fact that
a lot of stuff like you know the abuse
in those places that was there was a lot
of workplace stuff that was like super
unsafe you know we had it was only 100
years ago we had like child labor so a
lot has changed since the 1950s that i
think
you know of course it would have to be
highly regulated we have to make sure
there are a lot of checks and balances
to like you know make sure we're doing
it right
but
i mean
if somebody's got a
uh any kind of a solution like an
immediate solution that's actually going
to have an effect on these things that
you know again doesn't doesn't require a
total cultural revolution or some mass
religious awakening or whatever
i am very open to hearing it but you
know i keep coming back
to the fact that you know and and i saw
somebody else who put it this way i
can't remember who it was but just that
there are uh you know
somewhere between like 10 and 20 times
as many people
walking around today who would not have
been allowed to 50 or 60 years ago
and to take those people put them on the
streets or put them back in their
households you know where where their
mental issues were manifesting in the
first place
and then exposing them to all the
cultural changes
the the breakdown of community the
social isolation
um all of that
you're you're you're just
it's it's like when you get to the
pharmaceutical drugs right you know all
the pharmaceutical trials and you have
to be very careful with how you talk
about them because they're famously
litigious over this stuff but
you know um there's black box warning on
all anti all ssri antidepressants a
black box warning means
an advisory that there are not just
adverse effects adverse
like medication effects which are side
effects but to their serious risk of
injury or death
and that
specifically well it says anxiety
agitation panic attacks insomnia
irritability hostility aggressiveness
both of those which have very specific
meanings that uh are intent like that
you are experiencing violent impulses
toward other people uh imbulsivity
akathesia which is like you can't sit
still hypomania which is like mania but
not quite as bad
have been reported in adult and
pediatric patients being treated with
antidepressants for major depressive
disorder as well as for indications both
psychiatric and non-psychiatric now that
has to be on there because there have
been
just not only a lot of studies there
have been a lot of studies that have
shown increases in suicidal ideation
increases in aggressive impulses but
actual things that have happened when
you go down the list of the people
who have committed these
these kinds of killings
um
and other things too like that woman uh
several years ago who you know she
drowned her five kids in the bathtub um
she was on i won't say the name of the
drug but like uh she was on one of these
things now people will look at that and
say well yeah the people who are going
to go shoot up a school are people
probably have some problems and so
they're more likely to be on this stuff
and that's true
but then the thing that i always come
back to is
you know the fact that this stuff
doesn't tend to happen in the poor inner
cities
where they have gang violence all that
kind of stuff obviously there's plenty
of gun violence like so it's not like as
if they're just these peaceful
communities where there's no type of
violence but there are also communities
where
uh you know you have poorer families who
maybe don't have health insurance that
pays for the boys prozac or whatever
and the kid in the sub the middle class
kid in the suburbs they have access to
that stuff and you look at all of the
studies and they all come out and it's
like you said 99.9 percent
totally fine
uh
but we just started giving it to like
tens of millions of people like in no
time at all you know yeah and you
replace you replace the
opportunity to go to get somewhere where
you can't hurt anybody else and you
can't hurt yourself and you replace that
with just go on this drug which by the
way has these heinous side effects i
mean
irritability hostility aggressiveness
impulsivity
like that's what that's what we're going
to give someone
that's
that's already having a hard time
so
that becomes like a
a move
and of course you know when you know the
way these these
pharmaceutical companies work in many
cases they're
salesmen
they're salesmen yeah people in other
countries think we are completely insane
for letting pharmaceutical companies
advertise to people on television it's
illegal in most countries and they think
we are completely crazy the idea that
you just walk into a doctor's office and
say hey i saw a commercial like i have
this especially for something like
antidepressants where you know look man
life is hard a lot of times you know
especially like we have a a society
that's very competitive
um you know you you really gotta look
after yourself there's not a big social
safety net in a lot of ways you know
people are
just the way we our culture is we tend
to be pretty isolated from you know our
families uh at least large extended
family networks people don't know their
neighbors you know
you take all of that
financial pressures you know i mean
we've had several financial collapses
basically in the last few decades i mean
all of these different pressures that
are out there that life is just going to
suck sometimes it's going to really suck
for periods of time
and you see it you can see a commercial
that's going to tell you with the
authority of a doctrine you know a
doctor's authority when you see that
stuff that uh hey
do you ever feel bad about anything do
you ever just kind of feel down or not
have enough energy oh okay well you you
have a illness and here's this
people think in other countries think
we're crazy for allowing that and i
agree with them
yeah well that's that's not actually
only one flank that that people are
getting hit on because the
the actual doctors themselves are
getting
you know they're getting office visits
and office calls and dinner and uh you
know here's a nice little gift from this
and a gift from that and let me tell you
how we can help you and
th so the doctors are getting that way
too so then it's like a double whammy
you know you come into my office and you
say hey i'd like to try this drug and i
go oh that's great it's going to be
perfect for you yeah and so you're
getting hit from two directions and
listen there is i gotta look i work with
some
massive medical companies some massive
pharmaceutical companies and there is an
absolute reason
and there's some huge benefits to that
where you have people that are in let's
say working for a pharmaceutical company
or working for a medical device company
and they know the capabilities of those
those drugs or those those medical
devices better than a doctor's going
because that's what they do for living
so they're able to go in and educate a
doctor and really give that doctor the
ability to use the right medicine or use
the right device and it's
it is absolutely saves lives all the
time
that being said that zero one percent or
point zero one percent of the time where
someone goes hmm yeah this this should
work for you especially when you think
about these
uh these mental health psychotropic
drugs you know ssris or adhd meds or
anything like that
um it's not as if you know they do a
brain scan and draw a little fluid from
your brain to get the exact levels and
they're like okay you need exactly this
dose of exactly this drug that is not
how it works at all is anybody who's
gotten a prescription for these things
knows you go in there and they're like
you're not feeling so good you have low
energy you're not really motivated all
right well try this one
and in three or four weeks come on back
in we'll see how you're doing if we need
to adjust the dosage we will maybe we'll
put you on a different one it's it is
trial and error yeah and
you get this uh
i think they call it affirmation
affirmation treatment psychological
affirmation so when you come in and you
tell me hey i feel this way i kind of
affirm yes that's how you feel and i
support it we get that across the board
on everything now where instead of me
going you know when you come to me and
say i'm pissed at whatever
i don't say hey dude that's you
that's your problem you know when you
say i don't like my school i go yeah
well maybe it's because you act like an
[__] quit acting like an [__] and
you like your school more or you say hey
jessica broke up with me and i say yeah
that's cause
she broke up with you because you're
you're freaking failing out of your
classes she probably looks at you and
think where are you going to be in 10
years why don't you start getting your
act together
square your [__] away
that's not what's happening
no one's getting told they're getting
you know when you come to me and say
jessica broke up with me i say oh no
jessica sucks
jessica
is mean
instead of me saying bro you you didn't
work hard enough to get jessica you
didn't make the football team you need
to lift more
that's where we we don't have that we
don't have enough of that yeah and it
comes back to what you were talking
about earlier how a lot of our kids
social interaction has been has been
moved online which is just a totally
different environment you know for one
thing
well that accountability that you're
talking about right there that your
in-person interactions are just going to
have because you're going to see
immediate responses from a group of
people that you can't really escape
these are the people who are at your
school when you're in seventh grade or
whatever in 1980 right whereas now you
can just ignore all of those people you
have online communities that you go to
you can be a total psycho on one of
these things get yourself banned from
one start a new account and go on there
or go find another one or whatever and
so any
thing that you know if you can't even if
you can't find anybody around you who
would affirm all of it
you can just ignore those people and go
find it somewhere else online you can
get anything affirmed online
one thing i've been thinking a lot about
lately i've actually been talking a lot
about it um
talking about it from uh from on the
podcast i've been talking about on my
online training
uh as well
just and it's so horrifying
it's horrifying
and that is the malleability of the
human mind
and
we all think
well
we all think that this human mind the
strong will
free will we're all out there and if you
you know when someone messes with you
you mess with them back and someone
tells you something you tell them to
shut up and like you know that's kind of
how we feel we kind of feel i think
human beings generally we feel like we
have our own agency in what's going on
kind of just kind of it's kind of our
front-running operating system is that
hey i'm an individual i'm a i'm an
individual human being i have agency i'm
going to kind of do what i want we all
kind of have that front running
operating system
but man the the one layer below that
front running operating system
is this completely malleable thing that
you you you keep that that that surface
operating system running you're thinking
that you're doing your own thing and you
are just getting manipulated and played
and it's it happens on
on mass
um
i mean there's no better example really
than the nazis than the nazi party in
germany i mean go watch uh try them for
the will and see
hundreds of thousands of people that are
just on board they're just on board with
what's going on
that happens i mean your podcast with uh
talking about jim jones yeah cults are a
perfect example cults are a perfect
example of how people
you read it you hear it
you and the weird thing is it's a weird
it's a weird
it's a weird phenomenon that your front
running
sort of operating system thinking that
you have agency thinking that you're
making choices thinking that you're
moving in this direction because you
want to and because it's the best thing
for you and you kind of see it you
people have that going on at the same
time they have no idea
that they're falling right into a trap
they're following into they're being a
sheep following everything else that's
happening yeah like the internet
environment makes it so that everybody
can just kind of go join a cult without
the stigma of like you're in a cult i
even think about like yeah i go on my
twitter feed and like i'll tweet
something give me anything
uh and yeah every once in a while i'll
get someone who will tell me i'm full of
[__] but 99.9 because these are my
followers these are the people that
notice my tweets the ones who might like
it the twitter's algorithms push it to
and so 99 of what i get back is all
affirming
and you can just kind of head off in any
direction i mean one of the one of the
ways that i put it in that jim jones
series was
you know if you have somebody who is
delusional let's say which he was you
know early in the 50s he was having
delusions that he was getting messages
from space aliens that were telling the
nuclear war was happening and all that
you start to have something like that
happening in like most people's lives
you go tell somebody about it they're
gonna go
okay great and if it was 1955 they could
take you to somewhere and put you into a
place where you'd get some help right
and but now you tweet that out and what
happens i'll get 100 new followers in
the next two hours of people who all
think that you know i finally figured it
out and you know and but that's the
thing right what happens when you take
somebody who starts to spiral in a given
direction and put them in an environment
where all anybody tells them is what
aliens
totally what should we do about it and
uh you know i think we'll we see what
happens you know and i worry i mean i i
know this is maybe a little bit trite to
say these days but
you know like
like the the psychological mechanism of
schizophrenia leaving aside like the
the neurological and like genetic
aspects of it but the way like
schizophrenia often seems to develop
that's a broad category mental illness
obviously but
is it somebody gets you know withdrawn
and separated from those feedback loops
that they get from other people and once
that happens you can kind of just go off
in any direction i mean you get people
um
you know who well the mind can do
anything go read one of oliver sax's
books he's a neurologist who wrote uh he
wrote he got famous for writing that
book awakenings that became a movie back
in the day and then he wrote a bunch of
other books where he talks about people
who like have a you know
like damage in a certain part of their
brain
one of um his books is called uh the man
who mistook his wife for a hat because
something happened in his brain and he
just became convinced that his wife was
a hat
and you know you your the brain can go
just any direction in and it can go way
off over a cliff in any direction if you
don't have those social feedback loops
to kind of keep everybody on the same
page now sometimes you look at like the
aztecs or something i'm probably gonna
get in trouble for that one let's say
the nazis to keep it safe um
that sometimes you get a whole society
they can start giving each other that
reinforcement and a whole big group of
them can just go fly off a cliff
together you know that can happen too
you see it in smaller like doses with
cults obviously you know the interesting
thing about the social feedback on
on social media is i don't have to live
with you yeah so you're not you know you
you
you're gonna put something out i don't
have to i don't have to deal with you we
have to work together we don't even have
to interact i'm never gonna see you in
my life so i can do it just have a good
time just egging you on yeah and we can
join forces
where for me i'm just joining forces
because i'm having fun i'm a i'm a bot
or i'm a what uh uh uh was it a [__]
poster i'm a [__] poster so i'm just
yeah you tell them daryl you tell them
what's up and you're oh yeah and you
start going oh yeah you should check
this guy out daryl and you check some
other guy and this guy encourages you
too and you get these these
echo chambers over over used word but
you get these
social feedback where it's not somebody
that that i have to deal with because if
i work with you and you come into work
with me and you're talking some crazy
[__] i'm like hey bro hey what are you
talking about that's the dumbest thing
i've ever heard stop and you go ooh
i can put you in check in real life
whereas in the in the social
media world you're not getting put in
check by anybody sure there might be
someone else you block them and you
block them or there's 58 other people
that jump on board and smash that person
for you know pointing something out and
and so you end up in these in these
situations where you're just getting
worse and worse you're going further
down that rabbit hole and it's just not
freaking healthy it's horrible but but
in real life
in real life where i have to deal with
you
i go hey man you can't you can't wear
that in here you can't wear that kind of
clothes in here what are you what's
wrong with you yeah or hey you can't act
that way you can't treat that somebody
like that it doesn't happen in in this
in the in the virtual world and that's a
problem and by the time someone looks up
by the time a 16 17 18 year old kid
looks up he's already freaking got a two
two semi-automatic rifles and a bunch of
guns and a bunch of ammunition and he
thinks okay cool no one's put him in
check no one put him in check and was
almost like hey man what are you doing
talking that kind of [__] yeah can't
talk like that yeah like you remember we
were talking about um
like the journals are you know just
crazy [__] like when you're in middle
school in high school in your death
metal phase or whatever and you're bored
in class like drawing scenes of just
destruction and war and whatever writing
about death etc
um
now all that stuff goes online you're
not just writing in your little notebook
you're writing it online and there are a
bunch of other people who are giving you
that social feedback and social
affirmation for it and so now instead of
just being this little sort of thing
you're blowing off some steam or
exploring some ideas that are just
starting to come into your head
you're actually going and joining a
little quote-unquote like community
that's based around that kind of talk
and you know that sort of aesthetic and
feeling which is a very different thing
and uh
yeah it's it's
very dangerous
yeah i want to talk a little bit more um
before we wrap up i think we should talk
a little more about the media
because it's a huge part of this and not
just the internet and social media
because this all started before any of
that was really i i think it's an
accelerant for sure but this stuff did
start to change you talked about
columbine columbine was a turning point
in so many ways
and one of the one of the big ways i
think is that
um it was the columbine was the moment
maybe you saw a little bit of this with
the oj trial actually
um
but where
the 24 7 sort of disaster coverage
of something like that
with all the shock and horror and fear
and all of outrage and everything
became merged with the political
dialogue about that topic and those two
things kind of got put together where
so that now that's how everything is
reported you know from mass shootings to
hurricane katrina something like
something horrible happens and you have
all of the sort of shock horror and
outrage of the 24 7 media cycle focus on
this stuff and the sensationalism or
whatever
coupled with and the political enemies
that you already had the people you
already hated yeah they're to blame for
this and it's put together
in a very very toxic mix
and uh
you know i i rewatched the other day in
prep for this episode um natural born
killers
i don't know how long it's been since
you've seen that in a while it's um it's
a it's a
look it's a it's a much uglier movie
than i remembered it when i was a you
know uh when i was younger and i saw it
and maybe that's just because you know i
used to like horror movies and now i
watch it i'm just like ugh can't handle
this stuff anymore so i'm probably
getting soft in my old age and that's
probably part of it it's a very ugly
movie like it
doesn't hold back or like um but but
there's this one there's this one scene
toward the end where
uh woody harrelson the character is
being interviewed by robert downey jr
this is after they've committed all
their murders and everything they're in
prison and he's interviewing them or or
maybe it's after they escape with him
and he talks about he says the media is
like the weather except it's man-made
weather and i was like that's very it's
a very interesting way to put it
it's this like idea where you know the
media can like
turn the dial up a few degrees
or they can turn it down a few degrees
and i'm not
i'm not implying there's some
ceo up there who's doing that i think
but but you know it is you know the
media can turn it up a few degrees and
if you think about like analogy with how
like rising global temperatures happen
you turn
the temperature up a degree or two and
it's not as if like the entire globe
goes up a degree or two it's that over
here it stays the same and over there
there's like more hurricanes and over
there there's wildfires and a drought
and then over there it's fine
and so you turn that you know the media
turns that dial up a little bit
and
over here it's fine jocko and i we watch
it and we're like okay you know or or
you inject the uh
you know the violence in video games
just all the different things cultural
things we're talking about and we see it
and we're fine but then over here
there's like it's going to manifest in
this really monstrous way
and
you know i think that the media has
i will say most people aren't really
aware of this this was something that i
read in sue klebold's book though
um that the media there there are there
have been a lot of changes in the way
that they cover these things
uh at least the mass media the large
corporate mass media where you'll notice
that like very often
they won't show pictures of the person
they um there was a lot of outrage
including from a lot of people in the
media industry
back when the boston marathon bombing
happened and rolling stone put that
kid's picture on the cover and he's like
he looks like a rock star basically and
there were a lot of because they it
broke rules when they did that like
there were like these sort of like style
guides basically of like how do you
handle something like this now of course
the problem with that is all right so
cnn and fox news and you know the big
newspapers are going to follow those
rules but most people are getting all
this stuff from the internet these days
and uh
you know i think you know like watching
natural born killers actually
one of the things that made me really
uncomfortable about it is it is a
critique of like media sensationalizing
of all of these type of events and how
it creates this feedback loop that
causes these type of things but that the
movie itself like kind of does that
and i get that that's part of the
way they accomplish what they're trying
to do with the movie
but uh you know
the the columbine kids they love that
movie and they actually referred to the
day
that they were gonna go kill everybody
at school as nbk after natural born
killers
and so um
you know it's a uh it's a tough thing
because we don't you know this is not
some
uh totalitarian like uh
centrally planned like society where um
you know you can control all the way the
media handles these things you know if
the media wants to if rolling stone
wants to put that kid on the cover they
can put that kid on the cover and
it seems like if somebody can do it then
somebody's gonna do it
maybe not everybody but yeah so so
where does that leave us well you you
actually believe it or not i do have
some control over this you have control
over what stories you click on you have
control over what media outlets you
follow
you have control over who you interact
with
and how much oxygen you give them
you have
the ability to allow media to dehumanize
people human beings you have the ability
to say no to that you have the ability
not to watch certain movies you have the
ability not to you know
get your kids certain video games
you you have the ability to talk to them
through what these things really are
we we do have those abilities to do
those kind of things
we have the ability to
you know with the malleability of the
human mind
and how
open to
influence people are
well
you
no matter who you are have the ability
to influence people to move in a better
direction
to look at things in a better way to
form connections
with people
to reach out
to communicate to people in a positive
way
to not get hyper-emotional over things
this is something that we can all do
stuff we can all do
to turn off the damn the twitter feed to
unfollow
idiots
to not watch a news broadcast that's
hyping up some horrible situation this
is stuff that we all have control we can
control
a lot of what comes in you can control a
lot of what comes into your world you
can
you can control a lot of what you decide
to consume
and and i think
barring you know like you said uh
some kind of a
mass control over the media and laws
against this and laws against that what
we can do is kind of vote with our eyes
vote with our clicks
and and try and influence the people
around you to do the same thing
and that's a
that that seems like
that seems like a small thing
but but the reality is you have a huge
amount of influence over the people you
associate with
people are malleable you're malleable so
you're malleable so you need to watch
what you're partaking in you need to
watch what you're looking at you need to
watch what you're consuming
and
other people around you they're
malleable
and you can either press them to go
watch some stupid
hysterical
uh crazy thing on social media or
you can talk to them as a human being
you can form relationships with other
people
you can help out a kid that seems like
maybe he's a little distraught about
something
maybe you helped that kid you know get
that kid a pull-up bar
get that kid into a jiu-jitsu class get
that kid a guitar
talk to them about
where they can be in three years talk to
them about the fact that when you were
14 years old or 15 years old
life was hard for you too
talk to them about that so they
understand man it's gonna it's okay
it's okay yeah
it's yeah it's hard to be 14. it's hard
to be 16 years old
it's hard to get rejected
it's hard to not fit in
you you will
you will you'll be all right
look at this book read this
watch this don't watch that
that's what we can
do and that's what it's going to take
what can you do to help the people in
your in your world in your span of
influence and you do have influence
that's where i'm at yeah and the only
thing i would add to it is if you know
you're in one of those situations where
you don't want to stigmatize everybody
it's like this because it's such a still
such an incredibly rare occurrence that
one of these things happens
even as common as they are now but you
know what if you're in high school if
you're in college and there's you know
the kid there that nobody likes the kid
that nobody wants to sit with at lunch
the kid who people like to talk [__] to
or whatever um you know just be the one
who like goes and says hey man how's it
going not saying you have to be his best
friend just say what's what's going on
because to somebody who's in that
situation having somebody who is
you know not an outcast like them just
come up and acknowledge them and say
hello is often a huge deal and very
often you'd be surprised how often uh it
can mean the difference between them
hurting themselves or not that day i
mean sometimes people are teetering on
the edge
you know and if you see you know if
other people are
are are picking on the kid
be the one who's just stepped up and
says hey man
back off chill out i mean because i you
know nobody look when i was a kid
sometimes i would do that you know i'd
be the one to step up and be like leave
that kid alone sometimes i wouldn't
um sometimes probably a few times
i would join in
because
you know you don't want to become the
target or you want to be cool or
whatever everybody's trying to be
accepted when you're when you're finding
out who you are at that age but i'll
tell you that every time that i didn't
step in and i didn't say anything and i
was too scared or too cowardly or
whatever i
there there are incidents in third
fourth fifth grade that i remember to
this day and i regret and there's
there's no way you're going to regret
being the one who steps up and
and uh
stands up for somebody like that and it
can make a huge difference in people's
lives just having one person do that
it can make a huge difference
yeah every every single one of us can
can do that can reach out can step up
can can
can have so much influence you know it's
one of those leadership lessons that i
learned
is that you know when you're in a
leadership position you have
so much influence when you say something
positive to someone it really hits them
and when you say something negative
something to someone it really hits them
well that's not just from a leadership
position especially for someone that's
isolated for someone that's disconnected
for someone that's an outcast for
someone that doesn't communicate
properly with other people or has a hard
time doing it and what are they going
through in their life and what kind of
abuse are they suffering and you as a
person have such an opportunity and have
such a huge amount of influence over
other people
and
like daryl just said
don't don't be shy about doing that
don't be shy about trying to just trying
to communicate with other people because
an isolated human being in this day and
age with all the
horrible influences that are out there
well you can
actually be a positive influence
so let's go do it
with that
thanks for tuning in everybody uh
subscribe if you haven't yet check out
our other podcasts i've got jocko
podcasts warrior kid podcast
jocko underground
uh daryl's got another podcast we
mentioned it a couple times today he's
working on a new series right now i just
heard the uh the opening of the new
series
you contributed to that opening actually
about the labor movement yeah yeah you
you re-read one of things that i've read
in the past uh
thud right
um
i can already i'm already so excited
that you're covering that topic it's
about the labor movement
um
you can you can
support daryl by going to
martyrmaid.substack.com
and you can also just listen to his his
podcast martyr made
you can support all these podcasts by
getting some gear from jackalstore.com
or jacofuel.com
or originusa.com or you can subscribe to
my uh what is it i guess i have like a
little alternate podcast platform
jockowunderground.com
and i have a leadership consulting
company called echelonfront
ashlandfront.com
uh
one thing i want to mention to everybody
today is um a friend of mine somebody
i've talked to you about before well him
and another veteran friend are currently
doing an 800-mile kayak trip down the
atlantic coast
to raise money for veterans they're
through the garryson east foundation so
if anybody is interested in following
what they're doing or maybe making a
small donation if you can swing it i'll
put the link in the show notes right on
man um that's the first time hearing
about that i sent you link
check your text okay i'll check my text
where did you send it i think yesterday
okay well i'll have to go check my text
that sounds awesome very squared away so
yeah check that out as well do you have
the link on you can say right now
well i
no i'll put it i'll put it in the show
notes it's kind of long so one of those
long links they didn't get just get
jocko.com
so there you go another way to support
uh some people out there that need some
help right now
and with that
thanks for listening as things unravel
and thanks for trying to
prevent things from unraveling more it's
the best we can do right now
until next time this is daryl and jocko
out